should all young people be taught to
code in school maybe F most of those
interactions of computers are going to
be based on some belief in some cord
fairies and magic that makes things walk
that doesn't feel like a good way to
live I think they need to understand how
those systems work and what it means for
those systems to do things in the way
that they do them coding the means to
help them understand their the digital
equivalent of gravity we don't exist
anymore without programs running around
us it's very hard to do anything without
program running once that happens and
you start to look forward as to what
society may be in ho we may all fit in
it you know my own children my youngest
daughter was a scape user from about 12
months right so our farm a farm rumor so
their experience of computers aren't
going to be much different males what
what I think is most important though is
those people understand the world 11f
most of those interactions of computers
are going to be based on some belief in
some cord fairies and magic that makes
things work that doesn't feel like a
good way to live
cording is a really good way to explain
to people how a computer works if
nothing else it will tell you how much
air front energy is to do things it will
tell you how simple the computer is but
how faster that is doing things together
this illusion of being smart so I think
teaching people to call it is on
exposing them to cording give them that
awareness and appreciation broadly they
allow people to do what what's often
termed computational thinking they see
the one computationally and the
understand the ways in which computers
might work and the world whether you'd
anticipate them all becoming programmers
or you'd anticipate
them all having to program for
themselves I think as unlikely but I
think the appreciation is really useful
for them okay so you think this exposure
to coding is more like taking them to
the art gallery or the zoo so they just
get kind of a snapshot appreciation for
something I think it gives them
appreciation and it will become part of
their life okay so so yeah the
mechanical engineer mequivalent of this
is is Lego and McConnell okay we give
this to a children they understand how
things are built how they're constructed
how they fall apart but they have a
working sense of the world uncommon
right but the understandable how is
Belle when a large part of your waddles
digital they need to have the same
knowledge they need to know how that how
those building blocks fit together
and what makes them topple okay so so
people can understand your build things
too high they fall over or that what
that doesn't work so I think my position
would be that one is holding the means
to help them understand the digital
equivalent of gravity I think the the
issue here isn't to Train everybody to
to be a programmer I mean I think people
will meet selections and their life as a
as a develop through but it but it's to
put it's a fundamentally is to put
computing and cording on this same
footing as mathematics mathematics is
the language of science it's the means
by which scientific things become
expressed so children are taught
mathematics in order to do that
increasingly large parts of the world
are expressed digitally and through
digital manipulation teaching people
what about coding and programming allows
them to understand that part of the
world so the big push and that we've
that we've had in the UK about computing
and the whole computing at skills
movement has been the orientation
they've had two computers and computing
technology has been to think of them and
as tools that they use blamele so it's
manipulation and use of the applications
we really want and I would argue isn't
people that can use those applications
is that people the generation of people
that will rate the next versions of
these things lots of the changes that
we've seen in the curriculums and
changes in the chemist and the
curriculum of the UK will introduce the
concepts a program into people earlier
will expose them to and will let them
understand what it means to do that an
early age and that will low people to
make some real properly informed choices
in the life so we don't inherit people
with any in our skills and programming
or cords so we have to actually teach
that when they arrive is that acceptable
yeah
I would prefer I would prefer us under
standardized higher level of them
exposure to computer systems and to be
honest people knowing the lake coding
and the lake computers before they
register for a degree in it and and have
an experience of having done it it's a
particular style of thinking and that
you enjoy or don't so and particular
aptitudes and particular rewards and I
think people understanding those and
thinking about what those mean for them
going forward becomes kind of important
and I don't necessarily want to get it
to be about people in good about it
maths or people build about according
but there is a sense by which at least
kids know know what math says and they
now know what English is and what art
and literacy isn't and they can project
themselves going forward as to what
those are ask people what coding is and
they don't have the tools to say do I
see a 20 year career doing that I still
think is one of the most amazing
achievements of the world right so the
fact that I can I could send a message
on this device to a colleague in
California who will then send it on to
your device and this will happen within
seconds and the complex is to make that
happen is just to paint us and people
don't think about what's involved in
doing that and I think I think people
understand and that
complexity and understand the
consequences becomes really quite
important for a whole host of reasons
but that is because you're out isn't it
bad because there used to be people used
to go and watch planes because they were
the most amazing things in the world I
know I know
I taken indeed because I'm old and but
also the house grown kind of interesting
consequences so as an example of their
sin and and often this is because
information is is put together and then
the wrong thing happens okay and I think
computing is it's quite good at doing
that occasionally and able just two plus
two equal twelve and it will cause your
problem annoying those moments when the
computer is seeing one thing in reality
sin another becomes really quite
important to us so I am or the one
example that springs to mind is them the
couple and just don't say Boston
recently after the Boston Marathon
incidents where and the husband bought
himself a rock sack and on the same
point when his wife bought a pressure
cooker for the kitchen online and the
FBI turned up ok so they understanding
that the a computer program somewhere
had put those two pieces of information
and generated that conclusion becomes
quite important to understand what was
going on in their lives
and I think increasingly will see more
and more of the need to kind of think
about that and people to kind of
understand why certain things around
them on Harmon
you said you had two young daughters are
you in viewing them with an appreciation
for coding so I think both my daughter's
sure all the ability to disassemble
material would look and say them and try
and figure out how they want I wish that
and I will encourage that to be to not
stop at the physical boundary to move on
to kind of the individual as need to be
but equally if they think it dull I have
no control of my daughter let's be
honest